[Applaudissements] a
eu une belle histoire pour vous
il était une fois deux accidents d'avion ont été
mis en scène
toutes les victimes ont été dosées et
bloquées sur deux îles
huit sur un huit sur l'autre
bien que ce nombre soit sujet à changement
avez-vous remarqué de nouvelles vibrations entre
certaines personnes ici je suis désolé mais
j'en ai fini avec elle
nous avons tous commencé à vouloir être des choses
je voulais être des hommes ce n'est que le
début
mais la vérité est que
certains d'entre nous devenaient des monstres
nous ne pouvions pas les voir
nous  pouvait les entendre
les garçons avec un groupe de contrôle parfait
tu n'es pas seul ici ce qui ne va pas avec
moi tu t'en soucies juste c'est tout ce que tu sais c'est
dégoûtant
il n'y a aucun doute qu'ils l'
implosent mon Dieu c'est de ma faute
tu mérites toutes les bonnes choses dans ce
monde
toi  J'ai déjà eu l'impression que tu étais confronté à
quelque chose d'
implacable
je suis toi
tout ce que tu as vécu
il m'est arrivé la même chose
ce n'est que le début
toi